welcome to the show that puts you at the
center of the national conversation
about the issues that matter to you most
trusts and quasi-coating remain
Unapologetic about their pursuit of
economic growth
but tonight the pound is still
struggling forcing the bank of England
to suggest that it may need to intervene
the scale of the prime minister's plan
is unlike anything seen in decades it's
a huge gamble for the country
I'm Trevor Phillips and this is the
great debate
[Applause]
good evening each week we get to the
heart of the issue dominating the
headlines
tonight it's clear that the Market's
reaction to Liz truss's economic plan is
not for the faint-hearted at one point
the pound fell to its lowest level since
decimalization but the Prime Minister
and the chancellor insist that their
plan to boost growth through tax cuts
and greater borrowing is the right
course of action
our viewers panel from across the UK are
here they'll react with their stories
and they'll have their stay
joining us in the studio this week are
David gork former conservative Chief
secretary to the treasury
and the kelvoy executive editor of The
Economist
Gerard Lyons chief economic strategist
at net wealth
and Mick Lynch General Secretary of the
rmt so let's take a look at the big
question facing us this week
is list trust taking too many risks with
our money
we promised a new approach for a new era
we promised to release the enormous
potential of this country
[Music]
we were waking up to a new record low
for the pound again it's Fallen to a new
low against the US dollar I can't
remember another time that we've had a
response to a budget that's been
anything like this you're prepared to be
unpopular aren't you yes yes I am
well let's start with our viewers panel
as always and I want to talk to Lee
diebel uh lee you were I think a
conservative supporter what did you make
of Last Friday
well I I'm disturbed it's it's
officially looks like short-term
economics for short-term gains by this
prime minister it really does
so so my question would be does the
panel think there will be our children
and grandchildren to give up the tab for
the debt accrued by covid and the energy
crisis
foreign
that this uh leaves your your children
and grandchildren with
it's it's it's a a a tax cut for the
most wealthiest does nothing for the
average person in the UK with children
and grandchildren they're the ones I
think they're going to pick up these
debts all right thank you Lee let's talk
to Amanda Coleman Amanda uh you run a
small business in Wigan I think what
what um what's your take on it
yeah I mean my my problem is a bit more
here and now in that um I set up just
around the time of covid's got no
support because I wasn't
um eligible at that point
um and this uncertainty is not good for
small business and small businesses
um where you know they're one or a few
people they underpin a lot of
communities so my big concern is the the
basically going to have to increase
costs
um in order to manage and also I do some
work overseas and that is a you know a
huge concern as well with what's have
been happening today
thank you Amanda that's your situation
you've got a question for our panel for
our program
so and it's how do small businesses get
heard during this crisis and also will
this plan cause the pound to continue to
drop the question that she has about
tonight is will this plan cause the
pound to continue to drop Gerard Lyons
well I've been pessimistic about the
pound for a while back in February I
thought we would see a major Sterling
devaluation this year and we have seen a
weaker pound now we're in a situation
where the pound is now so incredibly
cheap if you were to take a longer term
view you would think this might be a
time to look at the UK but of course we
have so much uncertainty at the moment
it's likely that we'll see a periods of
further turbulence and maybe weakness
but it's very weak at the moment but
coming back bringing those questions
together what we've seen in the last few
days is a period of uncertainty partly
because I would say the chancellor in
his mini budget and to some extent the
bank of England last week didn't manage
expectations but I think the chancellor
even though he didn't do everything
right last Friday for instance cutting
the top rate of tax didn't make sense to
me I think he is right to try and turn
the agenda around and to have a
pro-growth strategy and that comes back
to answering these questions I want to
come back to the wider issue but I guess
right now now tonight people are looking
at that graph of the pound against the
dollar and indeed against the Euro what
do you think and mcalvoy what do
economists view on this I think it's
always very difficult to really guess
where currency markets will settle after
a big event like this and we clearly
have seen the pound take a battering
they said you know guarantee that it
won't take even more of a bashing in the
days ahead there tends to be at least
some level where that auto corrects but
it's really more important to think well
what are the markets saying with this if
it was simply if you look at after
brexit for instance you saw the graph go
straight down if you heard voted against
brexit you voted remain you said well
there you go yeah this goes to show this
is uh this is not a good thing but we
saw the parent come up again the pound
has been weak for reasons sir Jared
Lyons has also just referenced what
would worry me more than trying to guess
what will happen in currency speculation
would be what is being said here why is
it what is being said what is being said
by the markets what has been said by
investor is why are they not convinced
and the big task of reassurance now goes
to Liz truss and quasi-quarter we know
they're very good at shaking things up
we know they're good at disruption we
know they intended to do this and that
they factored in something like this
fall in the parent but what we don't
know is that they know how to get things
back on their feet again Amanda
um
have you heard what you've heard from
Gerard
um and has that given you any sense of
reassurance about the future of the
currency
no it hasn't unfortunately and I think
it's just as has been said this is also
of Uncertain and um there isn't a clear
kind of way forward
um I just certainly doesn't feel it for
people like myself who are trying to
look at what they do over the next few
months
okay thank you Amanda David uh what
level of confidence can you can you
offer if any I'm not sure I can reassure
Amanda because we're in a period of
great volatility because there is
uncertainty because the markets have I'm
afraid lost a lot of confidence in the
UK and the UK government and and I think
Anne Wright asked the right question why
why are we in this position what are the
markets telling us
and I think some of it is about taking
risks taking risks with the public
finances uh borrowing a heck of a lot of
money when times are tight and when when
they know that the markets are wary I
think it's also taking risks with some
of our institutions you know sort of
undermining uh the treasury sacking the
permanent Secretary of the Treasury on
day one I don't think was a good message
I think excluding the office of budget
responsibility who are there to provide
forecasts and make assessments excluding
them from Friday's event sent the wrong
message I think to be honest some of the
criticism of the way the bank of England
operates that we heard from Liz truss as
a leadership candidate and talking about
changing the Mandate I don't think that
sends a good signal either and I think
we've got to be careful about our
institutions as well as careful about
the public finances okay Mick Lynch um
you wouldn't be the obvious person to go
to to talk about the virtues of
capitalism but this is going to mean
something for your members what what do
you think what do you expect to happen
well I think for ordinary women and men
around the country they they are they
were worried already because of the cost
of living crisis people are worried
about their rents which are going to go
up dramatically many people in this
country lived in private rented
accommodation on a buy to let basis and
those small landlords are going to be
hit with mortgage increases uh
householders house owners are going to
be hit with mortgage increases people
will be worried about maybe unemployment
coming back as a result of this because
businesses will be careful about what
they're doing and I think the duty of
any government whether whatever stripe
it is is to provide some stability and
some certainty so that small Enterprises
sole traders who are you know a very
important part of the economy but also
reasonably large businesses who provide
salaries and wages for our people to
exist on will be extremely uh shaky
tonight they'll be thinking why is the
the global market giving a vote of no
confidence in a in a Chancellor and a
prime minister that just walked onto
stage and let's not forget what they've
been telling us is that they're going to
drive this even more radically over the
next uh year or so we've got a yeah
another final statement coming up this
is only the beginning right yeah and
then a big budget in the spring it could
be that they are completely Zealot about
this stuff almost on a Libertarian uh
version of free marketeering which we've
never really had even with fairly right
wing uh uh governments in the past and I
think a lot of people have been going
well what what kind of government have
we got here are they trying to look off
after the mass of the population and
create a stable economy even if not
everyone supports it everyone believes
in stability so that they can plan for
their own personal lives and plan for
their businesses and their sectors and
which seems that we're going into a bit
of Anarchy at the moment I'm going to
come back to well and talk to it I think
let's talk to John Bennett because I
know
John you've got some concerns about uh
the way this affects different kinds of
people in the population as Mick Lynch
has just been talking about the issue I
guess of equality
that's right I I'm a nurse and I work
with some very vulnerable people and
every day I'm hearing people who are
very scared very worried about how
these changes are going to impact on
them my my question to the panel is is
it fair during a cost of living crisis
that the wealthiest minority will be the
people that benefit the most from the
recent tax cuts
so your concern is really the what
people are talk calling the the re the
distribution issue here rather than just
whether it will work
yes because the way the majority of
people experience the economy is simply
how much they get paid and how much they
have to pay out for things
and those two things are getting closer
and closer one starting to overtake the
other which is is unsustainable it's not
safe for people
okay thank you John and how important do
you think this issue of
distribution is the government says it's
going full growth come what may but
there are people who think what is
equally important is to be seen to be
fair it is important to be seen to be
fair and John makes the the point very
well I do have a bit of a challenge to
it there because you can imagine a
perfectly redistributive budget mini
budget fiscal event as we were told to
call it was a pretty big fiscal event
wasn't it but it wouldn't necessarily
work it wouldn't help very much it might
make people feel that it was fair but it
might not be particularly effective so
if you look at that tax cut at the the
45 to 40 it's not a massively expensive
outcome it costs about 2 billion so your
problem with it is more is it fair or is
it not fair I'm not sure that that is
what quasi quite saying in this trust is
shooting for with this what they're
saying is we think that this will bring
back the animal spirits it will make
people perhaps who were working four
days think yeah I'll work the fifth day
people who perhaps are in a marginal tax
trap but if that itself doesn't work
then all you've got is the bad news and
the unfairness uh point but you haven't
captured the gains so perhaps my take on
is a bit different from John's but I can
see either way that you've got to show
it works if they can't show soon that
it's worked then I think there'll be a
redoubling of the kind of criticism that
John was putting Gerald you were saying
before that in a way the problem was
that the the chancellor hadn't done
enough or said enough or been articulate
enough but there's a more
profound issue here isn't there that the
shape of the package isn't going to be
the same for everybody well I agree with
that and the question suggests that the
person asking the question didn't think
the top rate should have come down and I
agree with him but I think a very
important point about last Friday's
package is that the energy price Levy
capping Energy prices plus reversing the
two tax increases that were previously
announced namely reversing the
corporation tax increase and reversing
the national insurance tax increase
which all economists agree is the tax
and job doing all that was the bulk of
the package and that prevents a deep
recession now the economy is still
slowing the world economy is weakening
so everyone benefits from that so I'm
not defending what they did on the top
rates attacks but the key thing about
last Friday that we're probably
overlooking here is that if we had
allowed a deep recession or if the if
they hadn't taken action to address that
downside risk we would have seen
unemployment rise public fire is blown
out of the water this is the great
debate up next will we end up with
Higher Living costs and greater
inequality in society or will the tax
cuts benefit everyone in the long run
do you have anything to say about what's
going on sir
as the pound goes down the inflation
pressure gets greater what we need to
hear from the government is a credible
plan for the public finances and and a
credible plan to grow the economy
foreign
welcome back to the great debate where
we're talking about the government's
economic plan and asking is Liz trust
taking too many risks with our money
's fiscal event he called it has been
described as a budget for the better off
with Britain's top earners gaining the
most in tax cuts
but does it come at the expensive
Ordinary People worried about how to pay
their bills well the chancellor and the
Prime Minister say it's worth helping
the richest in order to grow the economy
as a whole
well let's see
let's talk to some of those ordinary
citizens and see what they make of it
Julie Faye I think you're in Tewksbury
Julie I am what do you think about this
question
of how it feels for the ordinary person
it feels very direct for the ordinary
person I live in a small well growing
Market Town rural Market Town my
daughter is at University uh in her
second year and she is worried about the
bills that are going to be coming her
way
um I'm worried she's going to just get
cold and not look after herself because
she's worried about those bills
I see our food bank and and lots of
other initiatives being very very
necessary parts of life now
um and I've seen
um
crops rotting in the fields because they
there's nobody there to pick them
because of the government's immigration
policy
now we can talk fiscal policy
um and
you know all the pros and cons of
different things but at the end of the
day if we lose track of basic human
needs of basic human dignity and Equity
then we really have lost the plot
Julie thank you very much indeed
um
I wonder if we're going to talk to
Stephen Fairley who's in Bathgate in
Scotland Stephen
um we we've spoken before
um what do you make of it
uh I'm I'm the same I think that we are
going to be greatly impacted with the
current crisis for the garden special
the energy
um as a family of sales we've looked at
our energy usage by unplugging and
removing appliances
um coming off standby appliances each
night washing clothes at lower
temperatures it's all common sense
things that we want to do to try and
make sure that we can make ends meet
um with the upcoming autumn and winter
months we'll look to cut our gas bills
by cutting off radiators that we don't
use draft Thrift indoors and windows
turning down our thermostats and our
water temperature
I mean these are drastic measures to try
and get us through the colder months and
there's a possibility that it still
wouldn't be enough
will not go away until this government
can assist with the cost of living
crisis
hi Stephen I I was in Scotland over the
weekend
um uh besides the the temperature
difference
um what do you think this how do you
think this is going to go down north of
the north of border
um like a lead balloon to be perfectly
honest with you I mean Scotland doesn't
really have many puzzles with the gas to
their energy policy we do have some but
not enough
um and I think that our first Minister
has spoken uh greatly about it in the
past saying they actually have more
Powers they might have um even called
for an emergency budget to try and help
and assist people like myself
um so that that would have been
something to be with the light and going
forward
okay thank you Stephen
um and
the issues issue here is both the
chancellor and actually now famously
prime minister have said they know
something's going to be unpopular
but it's beginning to feel like it could
be so unpopular it's untenable
unsustainable I suppose they think that
they're in for a rock and roll ride they
can give it a little bit longer to feed
through and what we haven't really
reflected in fairness to the government
Trevor is the size of that energy relief
package I was just having a look because
I spent a lot of time in in Europe
Continental Europe and it is really
really big I mean it's an outlier in in
terms of the size and the duration of
that so of course your viewers that
you're speaking from which is the 400
pounds which I promised before and this
this long duration of it which
conveniently enough seems to take us
about up to the next election or or the
period before
funny that there's 18 months plus but
plus minus you know after that but that
is really big so I do think that the
government has to get some credit for
that if on the other hand you're going
to say well you shouldn't have done this
you shouldn't have cut taxes here and
you've taken all these other risks they
they are on a seesaw they do they start
to get credit as people say well okay
looking around people are not great
sometimes looking outside our own
borders but these are issues which
affecting the whole of Europe this
energy crisis cost of living crisis
Germany today business Outlook says it's
going to be a sharp recession it's quite
funny when you look at it and the thing
is as if we we're not aware of that the
government May at some point be able to
say this is not just us but right now it
feels as if the heat is only on them and
has given us context David gorpe but
you've been in you've been Chief
Secretary of Treasury you've had to make
these big decisions now this is like a
massive decision and I guess the
question about this one is whether it's
basically a Kamikaze Mission by the
government that this is some this the
decision they've taken will be so
unpopular that they won't last
well it's a huge political risk they
have taken uh in going for the
additional rates no one was particularly
calling for it uh I think it's a mistake
I happen to believe that we should have
competitive rates for internationally
mobile people because you know you want
to attract talent and high-earning
people to come here live here and pay
taxes here
but the the issue that we face over the
course of the winter as as we've heard
is going to be really tough and you know
we are going to see even with the
generous support package that the
government has set out by the way I'd
prefer if it was more targeted to help
the poorest but it is a big package but
even so a lot of people are going to
find this winter really hard and in that
environment that's precisely the wrong
time to be providing a tax cut to the
wealthiest Mick um what we're hearing is
how difficult it's going to be and you
said this in part one one of the things
that you've been saying uh along with
some other Trade union colleagues is
there needs to be coordinated action
uh strikes and so on which brings people
to think oh are we back in 1979 is this
going to be a winter of discontent where
labor the labor movement attempts to
bring down the government uh is this the
moment for
the kind of thing that you've been
saying to strike government that's weak
and popular
people who want something different well
we can't bring down the government
notorious parties is capable enough of
Bringing Down the government they do it
quite often it seems to me so maybe we
won't get time to do that I think it
looks awful people were expecting some
assistance for ordinary men and women
people on Modest pay and low pay and it
looks completely callous that's what it
looks like to I was at the labor party
the weekend a lot of Labor delegates
lots of people from Liverpool coming out
they are extraordinarily angry about
what's gone on and it just looks like
they don't care it looks like they're
disconnected from the feeling in the
country I think the country is ready for
a change I think they're expecting a bit
of redistribution now there's lots of
arguments how you do that and you don't
have to be a radical socialist to say I
can do something with tax thresholds I
can take people out of tax they could
have taxed the energy companies directly
and said to them we don't need all these
market prices much of the oil and gas is
coming in from UK sources UK Waters they
could have said to them unless you
control that prize yourself we're going
to attack you to the hill they haven't
done any of it it looks like and it will
be a transfer of wealth from Ordinary
People to the Uber rich and I think that
will be resented for a very long time
you may not be able to say it's exactly
but there's quite a lot of support for
that point of view on the wall here but
let me talk to somebody who
in the end may have to pay or benefit
from this
um Jamie Martin uh Jamie you've been
with us before I I think that last time
we spoke you were 16 so and you're now
17. happy belated birthday you've you've
got a point you wanted to make
yeah well thank you for the birthday
messages first of all um but um yeah I'm
17. um I've got you know however long to
think about uh potentially paying bills
you know that are going to be
ridiculously high
um and that and that is something that
I've now got to worry about massively
alongside lots of other things as well
as you know working and school and and
other things so for younger people
um I think that this this news that's
coming out of higher energy bills or
just higher
um cost of living
um it's a massive massive setback and
it's going to leave a lot of people in
the dark and they're going to be left in
a kind of spiral a downward spiral in a
debt trap for generations to call you
had a question for our panel Jamie
coming out of that
yeah the the the question for from me
was uh why should My Generation
Um be burdened with this debt
Gerard okay I think there needs to be a
sort of reassessment people are getting
I think too pessimistic it's right to be
concerned the world economy is slowing
we've heard about the European economy
slow and the UK economy is slowing we've
been hit by a combination of shocks but
the level of debt in the UK even though
it's high is still not as high to make
us worried about the longer term if we
put up the ratio of debt to GDP is about
90 it's the second lowest in the G7 now
after the second world war the ratio of
debt to just give you a comparison that
same ratio was 250 two and a half times
the size of the economy far higher than
it is now in relation to where we are
and the way it came down then was
through economic growth and in answer to
this question the government has four
options at the end of the day you grow
your way out of it you have austerity we
don't want that you raise taxes we don't
want that or you borrow in the near term
you borrow but the only way to really
make sure that younger Generations don't
pay it you grow it that's why we have to
have a pro-growth economic strategy okay
I'll come back to that in fact I think
um we have somebody who wants to come in
here who does actually share some of
that point of view Chris Roberts
um on the Isle of Man Chris what's your
view about this generational uh issue
well I don't regard the current economic
situation as simply a political problem
my view is it is the nation actively
living beyond its means with no regard
to prioritizing what's necessary and
what's not
um an example food and energy first
holidays and socializing second if you
will uh no government of any complexion
can be expected to constantly support
unrealistic Lifestyles without ruining
of the nation's economic future
it it it's a bigger problem than just
politics I think the the general public
and we as a nation need to face up to to
the situation we're in and not just
expect the government to give away money
every time you know we can't pay a bill
okay let me stay with us Chris but let
me just go back to to Jamie um to
paraphrase what Chris has just said uh
We're a nation living beyond our means
and we've got to grow up
well I mean yeah potentially I mean but
he's but this is a case of it's okay
saying we've got to grow up
um you know but I suppose it's a country
we Face a lot of problems and we're
going to Forever of course
um but you know as it was mentioned
earlier we've got to think long term
um and I don't think what's really
happening now is is thinking long term
to be completely honest and you know
it's not just my Generations but you
know my kids my grandkids
um they're going to be paying off future
debts and things for for short
Investments we've made now you know so I
think we've got to think long term a bit
more often to be completely honest but
um yeah I think everything's short-term
in politics now Jamie thank you very
much indeed
stay with us on the great debate up next
we're going to get an update from our
data and economics editor Ed Conway
about the state of the market and the
bank of England's next move
welcome back to the great debate where
we're talking about the government's
economic plan and asking is list trust
taking too many risks with our money
well the chancellor may not want to
comment on the markets but they
certainly had a lot to say about him and
his economic plan
our data and economics editor Ed Conway
has this analysis of the day the pound
hit its lowest ever level against the
dollar it has been another Roller
Coaster Day in Market it's all reacting
still to this well many budgets
certainly more than a mini budget wasn't
it and as far as masks markets concerned
well the reaction has been very big
indeed this chart shows you the pounds
against the US dollar the higher the
line is the stronger the pound is and
this is just going back to last Thursday
you can see it was around
1.14 13 1.12 perhaps at the time of
quasi-quarters speech but look at what
happened afterwards to the pound against
the dollar it fell fell fell fell until
today that's the weekends there that
line and now we can see what happened in
early trading in Asia it went down and
then gradually came up a little bit
there was speculation the bank of
England was going to step in and
potentially do something instead we just
got a statement from the bank and as far
as Market markets were concerned maybe
that wasn't really enough because they
fell a little bit further the pound and
fell but it's worth just focusing on
this bit the pound getting to the lowest
level that's been against the dollar
ever ever going all the way back I'll
show you this chart that chart is just
showing you the last few days this one
shows you the last century in a bit
going back to 1870 again the pound
against the dollar used to be about 550
over five dollars for each pound through
the gold standard era that was a period
of pound strength then you had World War
one that kind of uh called standard era
coming to an end uh there is the moment
that the UK left the gold standard in
1931 a major economic crisis and you can
see that as each of these crises happens
in 1949 devaluation you've got the 1976
bailout the pound getting weaker and
weaker through history there is the 1985
Plaza record that was the last moment
the pound was quite as weak against the
dollar as it is now and then you had
1992 ERM exit 2016 EU referendum and now
today a moment of History really with a
pound getting to the weakest level that
we've ever seen against the US dollar
but it's not just in currencies where we
have seen an impact here also considered
the government borrowing rates the rates
that they have to pay on their debt and
this really matters because they've just
committed to borrowing a lot more of
that debt that's decided in bond markets
this is showing you it's the 10-year
government bond yield basically it's the
interest rate that they and we as
taxpayers have to pay and going back
over the last year you can see how much
it's tipped up recently but you only get
a sense of just how the UK is doing
versus other countries around the world
when you add them on so there's Germany
there's France there's the us and what
you can perhaps just about make out if
you look at that red line the UK we used
to be more or less in line with other
countries and now suddenly in the last
week or so UK rates of borrowing
interest rates on government debt have
spiked up it's getting more expensive
basically people out there are saying
we're going to charge you higher
interest rates for your debt which is
not trivial given the government has
just come committed to borrowing a lot
more money that's for the government but
what about for the rest of us what about
for households because of course the
bank of England sets those rates well
they are having to do something similar
this shows you Bank of England interest
rate and here we're not looking back in
time we're looking forward in time
towards the future to get a sense of
what people in markets expect to happen
with interest rates and just for a kind
of recap not long ago the start of this
year in February they were expecting
them to Peak at 1.5 percent that changed
later on in the year by August they were
expecting 2.75 percent but look at how
things changed after Liz trust was
elected leader of the conservative party
4.75 you see how they're starting to
mount those expectations for what's
happening in mortgage rates but just
today look at that line up at six
percent the highest that's been for many
many years
and that's not trivial first of all
because a six percent interest rate at
today's high levels of debt is a big
impact and second of all because
mortgage lenders are already looking at
this and deciding whether they can lend
at the levels that they have today
already canceling some of their mortgage
offers right now this is already
starting to bear on many households
around the country okay that was Ed
Conway and we've heard from him about
today let's go to see what Tariq Ali's
reaction uh to it all was in Doncaster
good evening Tariq
good evening to you
um apart from making millionaires even
richer can the panel tell us of any
examples in the world where trickle-down
economics has actually worked please
oh well that's interesting trickle-down
economics and that's what you think's
been happening this weekend
yeah okay
David gork got any examples
well it depends what you define as
trickle-down economics look I mean I've
made the point I think this was the
wrong approach to cut the top rates of
tax in this budget or this fiscal event
and I think the focus should have been
on helping those who needed the support
the most it is the case that you want to
have an economy that attracts Talent
there that tracks investment
um whether you call that trick or down
or not uh is up to you but I think
that's yeah you've got competitive
economies with low taxes in some places
but it's not the only thing that matters
and I just want to come back to this
point about growth because growth is
right and Gerard mentioned it but you
won't get growth if you lose the
Market's confidence in your fiscal
position so we're likely to see interest
rates going up over the next couple of
years that will hurt growth and there
are things that we can do to help with
growth some of which were set up it's
not just about taxes we could for a
start try to improve our relationship
with our biggest Trading market so we
bring down some of the trade barriers
that we've now put in place with the
European Union that would be something
that would help growth straight away of
course the government might say you're
still fighting the last war and that's
still important matter it still really
is hampering our growth and I know
people don't like talking about it or
some people don't like talking about it
but it's absolutely relevant to how we
can turn our economy around you know
sort out that relationship with the
European Union okay
I'm a cowboy I mean you know there is a
framework here which says that we need
to encourage uh wealth creators we need
to attract people who get paid a lot of
money but are very creative and
Innovative and so on
um and there's been a lot of talk over
the weekend about
the barber dash for growth way back in
1972. now this is not that but can you
uh call to mind examples where this idea
that what you try to do is to promote
growth by essentially
giving some people who are especially
good at doing creating wealth some
advantages in the way that they've done
this uh on last Friday oh yeah there are
loads of examples of that and I think
trickle-down economics is often used as
a sort of it's already got a framing of
people who don't like it very much it's
sort of bad marketing of lower tax Pro
growth uh policies so you could look
around the world you could say a lot of
successful East Asian economies have
done some form of that Singapore is the
Singapore on Thames remember we're
supposed to be Singapore on Thames here
in London well let's see but you know
that's a good example where you make it
very attractive for people's calm to set
up businesses or other problems I think
with Singapore is a society but but not
being attractive on taxes not one of
them Reagan I mean oiled enough just
about to remember Ronald Reagan there
morning in America the Reagan boom
that's also where this aversion to it I
think comes from across parts of the
left but also if you look just countries
like Poland if you look to lots of
places we'll try to come what was
something more attractive to get Tech
hubs so Estonia let me get an example
because it's a nice country Estonia even
Latvia the Baltic states have tried very
hard to keep top tax down to attract the
most Innovative those who will power
growth to that extent I think we should
give that poor old trickle-down
economics the badly marketed phase a bit
of a chance okay thank you Anne
um let's go to the wall now and talk to
Judith Randall uh Judith uh and to
something David have been telling us
that there are examples where the idea
that you push for growth by encouraging
wealth creation and and so on uh that
they've been successful in other places
um are you at all convinced that that's
a possibility here
I I'm really uh concerned that we're
looking at this from the wrong angle
and uh I'm concerned that what has
happened is really pushing the country
so much that there's potential for civil
unrest
and that the nation is effectively
standing on a cliff Edge
what the country is being burdened with
debt and no plan exists to balance
finances
and failure to put a windfall tax on
energy companies is to me inexplicable
you can't see the students but there are
quite a lot of other people who are on
our viewers panel who are applauding
that let me come back in studio here
Jared Lyons worry about civil unrest do
you understand why somebody would feel
that way well obviously we need to take
all these concerns seriously I think the
important thing is the jobs Market is
still very healthy and that's good it's
vital in any country whether it's
Britain or elsewhere to look after
always those people in need and in
difficulty and you do that through the
overall tax welfare benefit system so
that's pretty key on top of that though
what one sees in the UK is that
thankfully we have a very progressive
tax system so if we take income tax the
top one percent of people who pay income
tax pay about 30 percent of the tax
collected the top 10 pay 50 so it's very
Progressive so naturally if you cut
taxes then those people benefit but
coming back to the question is vital to
ensure the economy doesn't weaken so far
those measures have been good we can
talk about the distribution aspect but I
think the key thing is for the moment
the jobs Market is still very healthy
all right so that will keep some of
those fear is at ease but we shouldn't
be dismissive of these concerns all
right thank you very much coming up it's
less than a month since Liz trust took
office she's voted in by 82 000
conservative party members
does she really have a mandate for what
she wants to do
well I give notice that Liz truss is
elected as the leader of the
conservative and unionist party
it's your party leader I intend to
deliver what we promised those voters
right across our great country
foreign
welcome back to the great debate where
we're talking about the government's
bold plan to boost economic growth and
asking is Liz truss taking too many
risks with our money
well three weeks into the job and the
new prime minister has wasted no time in
unveiling the biggest package of tax cut
for 50 years
but she spent the summer talking to
conservative party members who after all
were the people who elected her so how
could she be sure that this is what the
British people as a whole want
let's go to our viewers panel and talk
to an old friend Ron Knox Ron what's
your view on that the Democratic
question
my question is is there a mandate
for radical change and does the country
require a general election to do it
Mick there's a question let me make sure
we've got it down last question from Ron
basically is it time to call the general
election what do you think I think it is
I don't think there is a mandate for
what we're seeing this is a really
radical uh turn in what in policy and
approach I think it's I think it is
verging on the libertarian I don't think
anyone voted for that nobody expected
these two characters to be in these
positions at this time the labor party
is getting itself ready to fight an
election I think and you've got you've
now got a distinction between those
bodies which we haven't seen for a while
I think it would be good for the country
and addressing this issue about division
trickle down will cause massive
divisions in this society and I think it
could be really serious we need to
settle that through a properly argued
election campaign where all the bodies
including the Liberals and whoever can
get their stuff on the table or argue it
through in forums like this and all the
others that we have and then the country
can make a decision about how they want
to approach economic and social policy
and I don't think we've had that
properly and we can't leave it to those
people in those golf clubs that have
settled this election in the last couple
of weeks there are lions I would
approach it as an economist so in
different ways since the global
financial crisis in 2008 we in Western
Europe including the UK have settled in
to a low growth environment 10 years ago
the UK treasury told the then coalition
government because of wheat growth to
get the public finances into shape we
needed austerity I argued against that
that was wrong they used the treasury
two years ago said wheat growth to get
the finances and the shape we need
higher taxes that was wrong now we have
a government that's saying we need a
program strategy and I agree that the
next election has to be about much
election be coming soon no I think
basically we need to just try and
stabilize the economy now and get the
growth up and in two years time we're
going to have a really real fight but
from an economic perspective whoever is
in power we need a pro-growth strategy
built on investment and productivity
David well I'm not an Enthusiast for
this government but constitutionally we
have a parliamentary system as long as
the Prime Minister has got the support
of parliament they can carry on until
the end of the term but does it cause
that government political problems yeah
absolutely it does and there are things
that they won't be able to get through
the House of Lords they won't be able to
get through Parliament and and you know
if you pursue a an agenda that doesn't
have public sport then you will pay the
price at the next general election so
constitutionally doesn't have to be done
but it's a politically risky strategy to
depart from the Mandate that they had at
the last general election one and a half
four one against what do you think
general election now I'm going to say no
I'm going to disappoint the question up
because we do have a situation the way
that we're set up in Britain between
elections that the the Mandate that you
get as a if you change government you
can change your government without
always having to go to a general
election which don't forget also A
disruption of it and we saw it happen
from from Gordon Brown taking over from
Tony Blair I'm sure the charge will be
this is far more radical and we've
already heard that from me that is true
but I think it is trust and quasi
koitenga coming with something so new so
different we'll see pretty quickly
whether it works or not I think it's a
fairer next election to be able to judge
them on that and vote accordingly thank
you all very much that is all we have
time for this evening and it just
remains for me to thank our panelists
here in the studio David gork Gerard
Lyons Mick Lynch and Ann mcelvoy
as always it's you at home who are at
the center of our conversation and if
you'd like to be part of the program
next time get in touch email the great
debate at Sky dot UK
and for now I want to thank everybody on
tonight's viewers panel for taking art
and
keep talking at home we'll be with you
again at the same time next week for the
great debate
[Music]